and out what this C value is so that
this will be a perfect square so I'll
show you what I mean so what we're going
to do is we're going to take half of
this middle coefficient okay so we're
gonna take the 10 we're going to divide
it by two okay which equals five and
then we're going to do is we're going to
square that five and that gives us 25 so
we're gonna replace C here with 25 and
then now what we have here is a perfect
square and I'll show you what I mean
we're going to factor this and when you
factor it it's going to be X plus 5
times X plus 5 okay or you could just
write it as X plus 5 the quantity
squared now if you want to double check
you can foil this this is going to be 5
X plus 5 X which is 10 X the middle term
the last two terms 5 times 5 gives you
25 and of course the first two terms
will give us x squared but what you're
going to notice when you do this
factoring here is that this number here
is always going to be half of this
middle coefficient so if this was a
minus 10x this would be minus 5 okay so
this will always be half of this middle
coefficient okay let's do another
example so this one here x squared plus
5x plus C okay we want to find out what
C is in order to make this a perfect
square so what we're going to do is
we're going to take this middle
coefficient 5 we're going to divide it
by 2 and then we're going to square it
now this time 5 divided by 2 is 2.5 but
I'm just going to leave it as a fraction
and I'm going to square the numerator
and denominator so that comes out to 25
fourths and so that's what C is going to
be right there okay now if we factor
this it's going to come out to X plus 5
divided by 2 the quantity squared so you
can see it's half of this middle
coefficient and the quantity squared if
you want to double check go ahead and
write it twice boil it out you'll see
you get back the original expression
okay now how do we use that in solving
equations well let's take a look at this
one over here
the first thing you want to do is you
want to get the constant on the other
side of the equation just to get it out
of the way so let's do that first let's
add 10 to both sides okay so now we have
x squared plus 4x equals 10 because
these cancel each other out we're going
to take half of that middle coefficient
number in front of the X half of 4 is 2
2 squared is 4 we're going to add 4 to
the left side of the equation but we
also want to add 4 to the right side of
the equation to keep it balanced okay so
now when we go to factor this left side
here we get X plus 1/2 the middle
coefficient so half of 4 is 2 the
quantity squared equals 14 ok so far so
good
then we're going to do is we're going to
take the square root of both sides okay
when we do that the square and the
square root those are inverses of each
other they cancel one another out we're
just left with X plus 2 equals plus or
minus the square root of 14 remember
when you take the square root of both
sides of an equation you get two answers
positive or negative but you want to put
that in there on the right side of the
equation now we're going to subtract 2
and watch out for this here when we
subtract 2 from both sides I'm going to
put that minus 2 in front of the plus or
minus sign here we don't want to put it
over here on the right we want to put it
in front of the plus or minus okay so we
have two solutions 1 is negative 2 plus
square root of 14 and negative 2 minus
square root of 14 you can do that on
your calculator and get a decimal
approximation but this is an exact
answer
okay last example this one here what
you're going to notice is that there's a
coefficient in front of the x squared
term see the 3 there so what we're going
to do it's easier to complete the square
if this is just 1 x squared so let's
divide everything in the equation by 3
okay so let's do that right now so
everything you divided by 3 keeping the
equation balanced we're doing it to
everything so we get x squared plus 2x
minus 3 equals 0 now we want to get that
constant basically out of the way we
want to move it to the other side of the
equation so I'm going to add 3 to both
sides
so now we're down to x squared plus two
x equals three okay now here's where the
completing the square comes in we're
going to take half the middle
coefficient so half of 2 is 1 1 squared
is 1 so again just all I did was take 2
divided by 2 and square it so half of 2
is 1 1 squared is 1 we're going to add
that to both sides of the equation we
want to keep it balanced we want to
change anything now if we factor this we
get X plus 1 the quantity squared equals
4 okay and if we take the square root of
both sides we get two answers plus or
minus 2 the square and the square root
cancel one another out and now all we
have to do is subtract one to the other
side and we get x equals negative 1 plus
or minus 2 so two problems here are two
solutions negative 1 plus 2 okay which
is 1 and negative 1 minus 2 which is
negative 3 so those are your two
solutions that will make this equation
equal to 0 so this is how you complete
the square go ahead and take a look at
the video again if you want to review it
I'll see you in the next video